Alam alaikum doctoral.
>> My name is Nafal and I'm a technician.
>> Nafal.
>> I have a question about the universal
brotherhood.
Is it possible to fully embrace Islam
like praying five times a day, giving
zaka, performing Hajj based purely on
reason and logic? Thank you.
>> What is your name, brother?
>> Nufal.
>> Nofal.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Are you a Muslim or
non-Muslim?
>> I'm a Muslim.
>> Muslim. The brother asked a question. Is
it possible to perform salah and all the
aspects of Islam purely on a logical
basis?
Depending upon how good your logic is.
How logical are you?
If I explain to you about surgery, will
you understand?
>> I will try my best.
>> But will you be successful? I'm a
medical doctor. Can you?
>> No. No.
>> Correct. Yeah.
>> So just because you don't understand are
you deficient or the logic is deficient?
>> I'm logical.
>> The problem is in you generally yes
Islam is the most logical religion. But
if you say can I follow Islam 100%
logic.
>> Yeah that's my
>> your logic is limited brother. Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala is far superior.
Correct.
>> Yes. Yes. Everything we don't understand
as far as I'm concerned
I use a logical belief
to prove those things which are
difficult to understand. For example, I
tell the people that today of course
science is a very powerful tool for
logic. Correct?
>> Yeah.
>> Science is a very powerful tool. Logic
is there. Many places Allah says
will they not understand?
many places that means Quran is
instigating people to ask questions.
There are 332 times wakalu they asked
and three time Allah says cool tell them
it's a question answer book
and Islam is the most logical religion
on the face of the earth
>> okay
but our logic has not reached so far
to explain 100%. Okay,
>> there is no religion which is anywhere
close to Islam as far as logic is
concerned. Okay.
>> So faith sorry
>> let me complete.
>> Okay. I'm sorry.
>> But my logic says for example because
human beings haven't advanced so much.
My logic tells me that if you read the
Quran there is not a single verse of the
Quran which goes against established
science.
Not a single verse.
But there are some verses in which we
human beings don't have a reply because
we are not advanced.
So there's not a single verse of the
Quran which is against established
science. But there are some verses which
science hasn't reached so far. Neither
science can agree it is right. Neither
science can disagree. For example,
life after death.
Can science testify? No. But can science
say no also no. So it goes in the
ambiguous slot. Quran speaks about big
bang. The Quran speaks about creation of
the universe
21.
Do not believers see the heavens and the
earth for join together we clothe the
messenger. Do you believe in that?
>> Yeah.
>> Because why?
uh every knowledge in the Quran maybe
can be
>> sorry every knowledge in the Quran can
be
>> can't be explained by logic but every
logical question can be answered by
Quran everything in the Quran can be
explained logically I disagree with you
okay and every logic cannot be answered
by the Quran I disagree with you both
are wrong of yours
both your answers are wrong everything
in the Quran cannot be explained
logically majority almost all Yes.
>> I gave you an example. Quran talks about
life after death.
Yes, I have given answer for that also.
Alhamdulillah, I've given most of the
answers.
But I use
logic which is higher than the science.
I have given a talk on how to prove life
after death. Time will not permit me.
Now there is one simple logic of mine
then I go to a different level. One
logic of mine is that today if you
analyze the Quran on the basis of
science 80% of the Quran is confirmed to
be 100% correct.
So if you analyze 80% of whatever the
Quran says has been proved to be 100%
correct by science. 20% is ambiguous.
Neither right neither wrong.
like about jin
life after death heaven and hell.
So 80% of the Quran when it's proved to
be 100% correct not even 1% is wrong.1%
is wrong but some is ambiguous. So my
logic says when 80% is 100% correct and
20% is ambiguous out of which not even
0001% is wrong. My logic says inshallah
even that 20% will be correct. So it's a
logical belief.
It's based on logic. I'm not illogical.
Though you cannot explain some part of
Quran logically.
But my logic says neither science can
disprove it. So if science cannot
disprove it, cannot prove it, it goes in
the ambiguous lot. But if 80% is 100%
correct, not even 01% is wrong. So my
logic says inshallah that 20% will come
to know tomorrow, maybe day after
tomorrow, maybe later. You understand?
So it's a logical belief. There is no
other religious scripture which can say
that in all the other religious
scripture there are number of scientific
errors. There are logical problems.
There are mathematical errors. Do you
understand?
>> Yeah.
>> So therefore Islam is the most logical
religion. But can we prove everything
logically? Our logic hasn't reached that
level. So I as a D I try to explain many
things but can't say 100%.
We Muslims we don't follow because it
proves with we follow because Allah says
our reasoning is Allah says
I may understand or not understand as
long I'm as I'm confirmed this is
Allah's calam I'll follow it just
because I cannot understand it today I
will not follow that means I'm not a
good Muslim
but I being trained in medical science
logical person that's my main tool
Islam is the most logical religion it's
the best far more superior than science
what science came to know yesterday 100
years back 200 Allah says 14
and not a single word has been proved to
be wrong that the reason Quran is the
most logical book in the world Islam is
the most logical religion the most
refind hope the
Thank you.